here's a hard probability question
Lindsay randomly selects two distinct
days each week to go to the gym just
randomly selects three distinct days
each week to go to the same gym what is
the probability that Lindsay and Jess
will both be at the gym on the same day
at least once in any given week express
your answer as a common fraction
so we want the probability that they
will meet in the gym at least once in
any given week it'll be easier to
calculate the probability they do not
meet and then take one minus that
Lindsay randomly selects two distinct
days there are seven days in the week
and let's say Lindsay takes these two
days now Jess randomly selects three of
the days so the probability they do not
meet is if Jess selects three of the
days from the five days that Lindsay
does not go so this probability will be
equal to five choose 3 divided by the
total number of ways which is seven
choose three this simplifies to be two
over seven so probability they do meet
is one minus two over seven which gives
the answer 5 over 7.